teddy grams teddy grahams were kind of
underrated oh i love teddy grahams dude
and you know i [ __ ] with cinnamon teddy
graham oh
i was a chocolate band but i'm with you
oh really chocolate the other one was
honey right oh yeah
where are the flavors pull out the
flavors wasn't it a blue box too was
that original maybe
oh teddy look at this [ __ ] they went
woke with teddy grams now he's gotta be
holding up a [ __ ] butterfly what the
[ __ ] happened now he's gonna be saving
nature yeah he looks like a lunesta ad
over here he's got erectile dysfunction
what the hell happened to him daddy got
anxiety wait go to the old ones well he
was gay back then apparently he's got
the half shirt on the belly shirt she's
still good atlas chaps like jesus christ
got a little hat on he's got a ball gag
and a butt plug these are the new ones
what the hell is this nabisco the
[ __ ] you know it's an evil nabisco is
definitely one of those companies that
was trying to give women like breast
formula